humanity's reaction to kovid
i assume that you get into that
in the book
so
is the is the reaction and how split
everybody is right now is that
explained by evolution
well let's just say it's not in the book
because we actually finished the first
draft we uh finished it in the amazon
heather and i went to a very remote
field station called tippatini which is
in the most diverse habitat on earth we
went there to finish up what we had been
doing and that was january 2020. it was
january 2020 as we emerged from the
amazon literally as our phones woke up
for the first time in a couple of weeks
we heard of novel coronavirus for the
first time and wondered whether this was
going to be you know yet another close
call like the original sars and mers or
whether it might be something
more but the book was finished before
covid happened
that said the toolkit in the book does
allow
one to
work independently and to analyze what
one is hearing about
the progression of the pandemic and our
response to it and and
we have found ourselves
very uncomfortably
in some controversy as a result of the
fact that a proper grounding and
evolution does suggest that our response
to this pandemic is
largely incoherent
so
that's probably not where we should
spend our time today okay okay
well okay and
going sorry heather you go ahead no you
go ahead well one of the interesting
things about the timing was that as
brett said we submitted the first draft
and of course we had some more drafts
and so we did add a few little things
here and there we do have an afterward
that just very very briefly addresses
sort of what the what the global
response to covet has has looked like
um but
our what we then did almost as soon as
we submitted the first draft of the book
was we started this podcast of ours
darkhorse that brett already mentioned
and
that was started in part as a response
to what we were seeing is very confusing
public messaging public health messaging
around covet and so you know from the
very beginning for instance we were
saying
um
wow the
the evidence suggests for instance that
this is not a virus that transmits
outside this is not a disease that you
end up getting if you're outside and
furthermore if you do get it if you
spend time outside you're probably going
to be better off and so
um really it's the the logic that we are
trying to introduce people to in the
book the evolutionary logic of how is it
you know what are humans at an
evolutionary level and how can we
underst understand ourselves from our
historical perspective and also from the
perspective of how we have to move
forward
so as to best make decisions and not
just make decisions but interpret
the pronouncements that are handed down
from on high you know do those
pronouncements make sense or don't they
so rather than
follow the scientists you know
follow a scientific interpretation of
the world and try to make sense of it
for yourself
that said uh one of the central themes
of the book is something we call hyper
novelty which is a state of change that
is so rapid that it outstrips our
capacity to evolve in response which is
a remarkable thing because human beings
are by far the fastest evolving
creatures that exist because
so much of what we do is actually in the
software layer rather than in the
hardware layer it can change extremely
rapidly but the pace of change is just
simply too high and all through the
pandemic you can see
that
this is occurring i mean even just the
simple fact of the rate at which this
disease spread around the globe is the
result of new technologies that
epidemiology
is
now taking advantage of like air travel
for example
okay so let's talk about this hyper
novelty thing for for for a sec so one
of the experiences i think my family's
had and you guys have definitely had um
is that
i guess i've been put in a position my
dad's certainly been put in a position
where things are happening so quickly
that like you said you can't adapt and
so everything seems a bit fake and i
would say most of society at the moment
is probably in a similar situation with
the pandemic where it's like is this is
this real so do you guys have ways to
combat that because i assume things are
just going to get weirder and faster and
weirder and faster with technology so
are there things we can do to get out of
this to like calm i guess our nervous
systems down and adapt properly
yeah i mean it depends on the domain but
but yes is the short answer and
one of the things to do is to recognize
that it is
the rate of change itself that is
speeding up and to do what you can
um you know first at the individual
level to to slow your own experiences
down and that and to make them more real
more embodied and that of course is more
difficult in a pandemic era where so
many of us are connecting over zoom over
over social media
um but also to recognize and you know
this is this may seem like it's
unrelated but but i think it's related
and it's definitely a theme throughout
the book
that um
humans
as many of us as think we are innumerate
and you know many people are sort of
proudly describe themselves as i don't
do math i don't understand numbers
it is still a tendency to once they hear
a number once they hear that this thing
is better than that or that this gives
you a hundred percent chance of
something right that it's those numbers
that you stick with and there's a
reductionism that this obscures that is
is really an error and you know people
imagine that if it's if it's a number
it's scientific and so we go after this
what you know what we think of as a
pseudo-scientific approach to an
understanding of the world that you can
use scientific tools where you're trying
to recognize patterns
and you know as much as you can about
what it is that you are as a human being
and you recognize patterns and you move
forward with with care and rigor and
compassion for other human beings but
you don't assume that just because
something has been measured that that's
the thing that should have been measured
or that it is being conveyed to you
properly so that's that's part of it
it's also i mean it's consistent with
not being overly focused on the
quantification but
the fact is you're looking at patterns
and they function especially in the
realm of biology
in a logical way and so
one could in the early days of the
pandemic for example make a lot of
headway by simply reviewing the evidence
that was emerging and so
we looked at the evidence that said that
a huge number of cases in asia had been
looked at and with one exception none
could be traced to an outdoor
environment and we thought well that
rather changes everything doesn't it it
makes it appear potentially like
although we are being told that
everything is dangerous that in fact
most of the world above 99 that's
outdoors might well be safe
well what does that mean
it could mean a number of things it
could mean that uv light from the sun is
killing the virus in which case you need
to be careful at night and not during
the day well it turned out uv light does
kill the virus but the virus still
didn't transmit outdoors at night and so
the model developed and what we said
back then was take advantage of this
this is a great loophole that the the
pandemic has in it that we can make use
of that we can live normally outdoors
but
we have to be very careful because
viruses that come from wild creatures
and one way or another this one
ultimately has to have come from bats
those viruses have to transmit outdoors
and so if this virus has forgotten how
to do that it will learn it again if we
give it that opportunity
so we we cautioned people
make use of the outdoors take advantage
of it restore your psychology by
behaving more normally outside but be
cautious don't give it the chance to
move or it will learn this trick and we
will lose that advantage and all of that
was just simply a matter of looking at
evidence figuring out what the patterns
were and extrapolating carefully from
them
okay well that makes sense to me that's
certainly not what we did but it makes
sense
[Music]